欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
第四小节我们来讲一下关于橱窗产品怎么样去查排名和怎么样去提升关键词的排名
提升关键词排名的这个方法适用于整个店铺所有的板块
第一个就是橱窗产品要怎么样去查排名
首先你要把橱窗产品的关键词整理在一个表格
或者是你在发产品的时候就已经有了一个比较明确的关键词表
第二个就是你要做排名的时候一定要在加入橱窗前你要查询一下这些关键词的排名和加入橱窗后一小时以后的关键词排名这样去做对比才知道哪些产品加入橱窗之后它的排名是有促进作用的哪些是没有促进作用的因为并不是所有的产品加入橱窗都会有排名的提升它仅部分的
词有排名提升而已, 第二个就是如何提升关键词的排名, 你想要提升关键词的排名, 第一个就是你要提升这个关键词的整体的点击量, 你必须从点击量先开始提升, 那么点击量积累的越多, 那么你的排名就容易提升, 如果你这个词除了有点击量, 还有询盘TM, 或者是订单, 那么他的排名能够提升的更快,
也就是你第一要有点击量, 第二就是有商机, 第三就是有订单, 如果你这些数据刚好形成一个闭环, 有点击, 有询盘, 有订单, 那么这个词的排名就会提升得非常的快, 所以说你后期只要去做排名, 你就要知道我要提升点击量, 还有它的商机转化, 这里其实就包含了一个商机转化率,
所以说这些都是你要重视的内容, 然后去提升的内容, 才能够更有效的提升你关键词排名, 最后我们来讲解几个常见的误区, 第一个就是智能橱窗要不要开启, 通常来说, 如果你的橱窗的整体效果非常畅, 也不知道加入哪些产品的时候, 那么可以建议你开两到三个智能橱窗, 进行一个测试, 看一下它的循环转化效果怎么样,
如果它转化效果很好,那么你继续保持两到三个自动橱窗开启,如果效果差,那么你全部把它关闭,全部采用手动设置橱窗,第二个就是橱窗产品要不要加入自动车推广,其实橱窗跟推广是不冲突的,因为橱窗是对产品标题的所有关键词都有加权的作用,加权的作用并不代表它能够展示在首页,
首页的广告位
而你直通车的推广仅针对部分的词进行推广
部分词推广呢他展示的位置是在广告位
如果你的直通车推广这些关键词
被点击的
多了
那么这里的点击被点击的多了
是不是他也可以促进你这些关键词排名提升
关键词排名提升
他本身又有点击量是不是
你橱窗的加权效果更明显
也就是你提升的排名是不是会更快一点, 相当于
双重扶持,那么你是不是这个
对应的关键词的层底的排名
的速度更快一点
第三个就是橱窗产品要不要绑定顶展产品
可以绑定,这是不冲突的
顶展只是其中的一个关键词
是顶展,只有这个词是能够排在国际站
首页的顶展的这个广告位,但是呢你橱窗
加权的时候,不一定给这个顶展加权,但是你可以给
顶展的这个产品的其他关键词加权,是不是你这个产品既有顶展又有自然排名在下方
是不是很有可能就实现双曝光,也就是你这个顶展曝光一次一次
那么你自然排名
通过绑定橱窗
排名这个词
提升了
那么是不是
也有曝光的机会在自然排名
另外就是
其他的关键词除了顶展这个A关键词那么你还有B
C
D
F等等这些关键词是不是也有排名的促进作用
所以说你的橱窗产品绑定顶展
是没有什么冲突的
因为这些顶展只针对的是
单个关键词, 而你的橱窗是针对多个关键词, 这是不冲突的, 所以这个概念一定要理解清楚, 同时呢不要纠结, 感于去使用资源的叠加, 累积让你的产品效果更好, 最后我们来后台演示一下如何去查它的排名, 首先我们把这个产品定义成A, 我收集的关键词是这些, 是我收集的关键词, 我用这些关键词
我这个关键词组合成了一个标题, 这个标题我组合成这个标题, 然后从另外一些关键词里面去挑选出三个K, K2, K3, 跟这里面是不重合的, 我这些也是在描述同一款产品都是A产品, 也就是我的标题跟K, K2, K3, 都是在描述A产品, 那么在产品A绑定橱窗之前, 我就去查这些关键词, 还有
这几个关键词的排名
看看他的排名是怎么样的
先查比如说这个词的排名我可以在
这里我用了一个插件, 查排名, 查排名
那么查排名的时候我新建一个页路, 把关键词导入添加
选择店铺
选择
第一个店铺
我这里的话可能选了两个
其他国家IP选美国英国
就可以了
前三页
开始查询
这是在绑定前查询的
我那个产品并不是
有排名的,我只是模拟路径给你们看
比如说这里我查询的出来
它是没有排名
假设我这里显示
排名是吧
没有排名,那么我这里就
对这个表格就是
它的排名
比如说我插入一列
无排名
这个排名
第1页
20名, 第2页, 20名, 第3页, 5名, 你看, 比如说这些都是, 我已经全部去弄好出来了, 弄好出来了, 这三个, 关键词, KK2, K3也, 把它查好, 排名, 查出来了, 查出来之后, 我这里是模拟的, 不是真实的, 就是我告诉你的是这个方法和路径, 你可以直接, 把这个产品A加入到储存, 把这个产品,
直接加入到橱窗
你把它加入到橱窗
在这里移除一个添加进橱窗
进橱窗之后一小时以后
一小小时以后
我们就去再次查它的排名把这些词
全部复制
在这里新建个任务
继续
全部全部来这里查, 选择店铺一样
继续查一下
把它们的排名
把它们查了之后, 我们把它的排名
放在这一列
这是加入, 橱窗前, 就是加入, 橱窗, 橱窗后的排名, 你就按照这里把它排名, 比如说这个有所上升, 第二名可能上升了两名18, 比如说这里没变, 还是没变, 这里也没变, 这里没变, 也就是说他这些词, 跟这里的这三个词, 很可能就是部分排名提升
有很多排名是不会变化的
所以这个就是你想要去查询排名的时候
按照这个逻辑这个思路去做就可以了
这个就是关于橱窗产品排名
那么你如果是想做得更加详细的话
如果你很多产品的话
我不建议你全部都用这种方法去做
你只需要去把握住一些重点的产品
不必所有的产品都去做
比如说你70个橱窗
你每个都这样做
那么你这样的话,你就是变成了统计员, 而你的实际的工作是为了提升效果, 而不是去统计数据, 你只要知道这个逻辑, 然后快速的去判断, 去应用就可以了, 并不需要你把所有的时间精力都花在那些那些记录数据上面
那么这个就是关于橱窗产品, 怎样去查排名和提升排名的方法
那么如果你还没有用过这些方法,或者现在思路比较混乱,那么可以先试着去操作一遍, 理顺一下, 只有去操作了, 去感受了, 你才能够得到更深的理解, 才能够更加灵活的应用
那么我们下节课再见, 这节课就先讲到这里